مشروب البود او ما يسمى بعصير الغلابه
ومشروم مكون من الدقيقه وبقايا الخبز
والشعير يضاف اليه الماء والسكر والفانيلا
وماء الورد يباع في الاسواق المصريه من
قبل باعه متجولين هناك المشروب من اشهر
المشروبات الشعبيه في مصر ومن يوم الجمعه
اسمه متصدر المنصات وجدى الكبير حوله
السبب حالات تسمم اصابه 30082 شخصا في
محافظه قنا في مصر ما حدث انه توافد الى
ثلاثه مستشفيات محافظه قنا اعداد من
المصابين بدت عليهم اعراض التسمم بسبب
تناولهم مشروب البوضه من احد الباعه في
احد الاسواق هناك ومن بعد ان تم ابلاغ
السلطات المختصه من قبل المستشفيات عن تلك
الحالات شكلت النيابه العامه فريقا ليقوم
بالسؤال المصابين حول السبب اجتمعت
رواياتهم بشعورهم بالاعياء الشديد بعد
تناولهم المشروب من احد الباعه تمكنت
النيابه العامه من القبض على البائع وحبسه
لمده اربعه ايام على ذمه التحقيق بسبب
بيعه وتداوله مشروبات فاسده في اماكن غير
مستوفيه الاشتراطات للنظافه الصحيه وبسبب
عدم حصوله على رخصه من السلطات المختصه
لبيع المشروب ولابد مشاهدينا هنا انوه ان
المشروب يتم بيعه في الاسواق من قبل باعه
متجولين وبالتالي من الصعب التاكد من
ترخيصهم ومراعاتهم للشروط الصحيه طبعا
المصابين غادروا المستشفيات بعد تحسن
حالتهم لكن الجدل حول المشروع لم ينتهي
والانقسام في وجهات النظر حوله سيد الموقف